RFK Jr as predicted over the past couple
of days announces he is running not as a
Democrat for president anymore but as an
independent we have to acknowledge the
truth we do face a decaying
infrastructure and record record levels
of suicide depression addiction chronic
disease we do face an entrenched
political corruption and an inequality
of wealth not seen in a century but the
good news is that people like yourselves
are finally set
up
[Applause]
something something is stirring at us
that says it doesn't have to be this way
and that's why I'm here today I'm here
to declare myself an independent
candidate some conservatives are worried
I'm not worried Bobby Kennedy I think
takes more votes many more votes away
from Joe Biden than he does from Donald
Trump